you are on the number one show right now
so what is the biggest perk of being on
that number one show on television uh
getting to do the job honestly I love
doing it I love filming the show I love
being in Montana with all these amazing
people that's the biggest perk 100 which
character do you feel is facing some of
the biggest challenges this season
oh man uh it's tough you know I think
that this shows sort of uh the whole
thing is the drama right the whole thing
is about how much can we put these
people through but I think uh in this
season it's Monica for sure yeah she's
she's going through some some pretty
heavy stuff and I saw the first episode
and you guys unpacked so much in that
first episode
at the same time for fans I mean it sets
quite the stage for what's to come or
what can come this season that being
said what are three words you would use
to describe season five
keeps getting better here y'all are good
y'all been asked that before maybe I got
asked it a hundred times today okay well
sorry for being so vanilla
just kidding by the way you're tall wow
I am a tall girl you're very tall you
know I've never met you sitting down I
know I you know what I'm a Southern girl
I am not five six okay she's just a very
tall one I have my big girl shoes on but
I also love my carbohydrates and I think
that's probably where I get a lot of my
nutrition to be so tall
um John Dutton taking on the Governor's
role this season if Kevin Costner were
to really run for office
what kind of politician would he be
oh that's tough tough to also answer
without getting in trouble in some way
oh you think it's still a political
question right no not really well I
guess he'd be you know A Gentle Leader
that's what he'd want to hear what do
you think of Kevin Costner it's just I
mean he is everyone's night in shining
armor yeah you know agreed I mean he
total Swoon catch me Luke catch me okay
look fans are super pumped we're getting
14 episodes this season amazing but
they're a little concerned because
they're broken up into halves so we get
first seven seconds seven does that mean
the show is like the show's end is near
um I don't know honestly I learned Kevin
haven't shared anything with you all
about it no uh no Taylor hasn't said
anything and uh but I do know that he
won't take it past where it's supposed
to go you know sometimes with these
shows that get to this level they can go
on and on and on and on and I don't
think our show will do that so we'll see
we'll see where it goes how long would
you love to play Casey uh I want a bkc
so I do it forever dude you are Casey I
am Casey I mean that first scene and
like one of those scenes in the first
episode you doing when some of your
roping so much fun it's like it's a
dream Cowboy Take Me Away have fun
congratulations